It's peak pollination season, and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speed. That's why I chose Google Fi Wireless. My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans started $35 a month. Now that's a deal that doesn't stay. Explore GoogleFi Wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees.
现在是授粉高峰期，我的业务规模正在迅速扩大。为了保持花蜜源源不断，我需要一个拥有最高优先级数据速度的手机套餐。这就是我选择 Google Fi Wireless 的原因。即使蜂巢里嗡嗡作响，我的连接依然稳固。此外，无限流量套餐每月仅需 35 美元起。这可是一个不会一直有的优惠。立即探索 Google Fi Wireless 套餐吧。另需缴纳税费和政府费用。
GoogleFi Wireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. If you've bought anything in the last few years, you've probably encountered a new way of paying for your purchases. When you check out at the grocery store or hit pay now in your online shopping cart, you're asked, do you want to pay in full today or split your purchase into four installments to be paid over time? The prevalence and popularity of these buy now pay later services has surged in recent years. One 2025 survey found that more than half of Americans had used. the Buy Now Pay Litter Service, such as After Pay, Clarnah, or Zip in the prior 12 months. Today we're going to explore the psychology of spending, budgeting, and debt, including
Google Fi Wireless 在网络高负载时段不会受到数据流量降速的影响。如果你在过去几年里买过东西，你可能已经接触到了一种新的支付方式。当你在杂货店结账或在网上购物车的“立即支付”按钮上点击时，系统会问你：是今天全额支付，还是将购买金额分成四期分期付款？近年来，这些“先买后付”服务的普及率和受欢迎程度激增。2025 年的一项调查发现，超过半数的美国人在过去 12 个月内使用过 Afterpay、Klarna 或 Zip 等“先买后付”服务。今天，我们将探讨消费、预算和债务的心理学，包括
the rise of Buy Now Pay Later services. How does the way we pay for a purchase affect our spending decisions? Why is it so easy to overspend? Why do people not pay off their credit card balances even when they have the cash? And how can we make better financial decisions in an increasingly complex and tempting financial landscape. Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life.
“先买后付”服务的兴起。我们支付购买费用的方式如何影响我们的消费决策？为什么超支如此容易？为什么人们即使手头有现金也不偿还信用卡余额？在日益复杂且充满诱惑的金融环境中，我们该如何做出更好的财务决策？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。
I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Abigail Sussman, the V. Dwayne Rath Professor of Marketing at the University of Chicago Booth School of Business. She studies the psychological biases that lead people to make errors in budgeting, spending, borrowing, and investing. Her research investigates questions at the intersection of psychology, economics, and finance,
我是 Kim Mills。今天的嘉宾是芝加哥大学布斯商学院市场营销学教授 Abigail Sussman 博士。她研究导致人们在预算、消费、借贷和投资方面犯错的心理偏差。她的研究调查了心理学、经济学和金融学交叉领域的问题，
with the aim of improving people's financial well-being. Her work has been featured in top academic journals, including the Journal of Consumer Research, the Journal of Experimental Psychology, and the Journal of Finance, as well as popular media outlets, including National Public Radio, the New York Times, and the Wall Street Journal. She recently spoke to APA's magazine Monitor on Psychology for an article about the psychology of debt and buy now pay later loans. Dr. Sussman, thank you for joining me today. Thank you so much for having me.
旨在改善人们的财务状况。她的研究成果发表在《消费者研究杂志》、《实验心理学杂志》和《金融杂志》等顶级学术期刊上，并被美国国家公共电台、《纽约时报》和《华尔街日报》等大众媒体报道。她最近接受了美国心理学会杂志《心理学监测》的采访，谈论了关于债务和“先买后付”贷款的心理学。Sussman 博士，感谢您今天参加我的节目。非常感谢您的邀请。
I'm really happy to be here. So I want to start by talking about what I mentioned a moment ago in the introduction, which is these buy now, pay later services that have spiked in popularity. What do we know about how they change people's spending behavior? Well, so one of the things that we know is that they lead people to spend more. And we can think about what happens in terms of the underlying psychological. here, which is that you go to make a purchase and you learn that instead of having to pay $100 today, you only have to pay $25.
我很高兴能来到这里。我想从我刚才在介绍中提到的内容开始谈起，那就是人气飙升的“先买后付”服务。关于它们如何改变人们的消费行为，我们了解到了什么？嗯，我们知道的一点是，它们会导致人们花更多的钱。我们可以思考一下其背后的心理机制：当你去购买一件商品时，你发现今天不必支付 100 美元，而只需要支付 25 美元。
And all of a sudden, the purchase that seemed really expensive suddenly feels very affordable. And if you don't really stop to think through what the implications are, you think actually maybe I can buy four different things for $25 and spend the same $100 that I had intended to spend today for the single product. And so as a result, it leads us to spend more without really feeling like we're doing so. Well, why does buying something with installment payments feel different from just putting it on a credit card? You know, I think that one of the main characteristics that differentiates the Buy Now Pay Later plans is the sticker price. And so when you pay for something using a credit card, the cost that is displayed to you is the full cost of the product.
突然之间，原本看起来很贵的商品变得非常实惠。如果你没有停下来仔细思考这意味着什么，你可能会想：“其实我可以用同样的 100 美元预算买四件不同的东西，而不是只买这一件。”结果就是，它让我们在不知不觉中花得更多。那么，为什么用分期付款购买商品与用信用卡支付感觉不同呢？你知道，我认为区分“先买后付”计划的主要特征是标价。当你使用信用卡支付时，显示给你的成本是产品的全额成本。
when you buy something using a buy now pay later plan, what you're really seeing is the cost of the payment that you're making today. And so even if for the credit card, you might actually put something on your credit card and not pay any of it off for, let's say, a month, but you're very aware of the fact that the amount that you're going to be paying is the full price and that in some sense you're borrowing the full price of the item versus the buy now pay later plan, you're focused on the amount that you're paying today, and it really dissociates the amount that you're going to be paying in the future periods. Let's stepping back for a minute. Your research has looked more broadly at why we overspend and make
当你使用“先买后付”计划购买商品时，你真正看到的是你今天需要支付的金额。所以，即使对于信用卡，你可能会刷卡消费，比如一个月内不还款，但你非常清楚你需要支付的是全额价格，在某种意义上，你是在借贷商品的全部价格；而相比之下，在“先买后付”计划中，你关注的是今天支付的金额，这实际上将你未来需要支付的金额与当前的购买行为分离开来了。让我们退一步想一想。您的研究更广泛地审视了我们为何会超支并做出
less than optimal financial choices. And one thing you've found is that we aren't very good at accounting for unexpected expenses in our budgets. Can you talk about that work? Yeah, for sure. So I guess I would say why we maybe overspend relative to what we would expect to spend. It's hard to say what's optimal in that in some cases we also are underspending. So we don't always give ourselves the pleasures that maybe would be beneficial. So it sort of depends on who you are and who you're, what your financial situation is, what the optimal level is. But often we overspend relative to what we expect or relative to what we would plan for ourselves. And I think those cases, we could really describe this sort of suboptimal. And so a lot of this research started actually before I became
次优的财务选择。您发现的一点是，我们在预算中不太擅长考虑意外支出。您能谈谈这项工作吗？是的，当然。所以我想说，为什么我们相对于预期支出而言可能会超支。很难说什么是“最优”的，因为在某些情况下，我们也存在支出不足的情况。所以我们并不总是给自己提供可能是有益的享受。这取决于你是谁，你的财务状况如何，以及什么是最优水平。但通常我们相对于预期或计划的支出而言会超支。我认为在这些情况下，我们可以将其描述为次优的。事实上，这项研究的很大一部分始于我成为
a psychologist. I was working in equity research and studied airlines. And so one of the things that I noticed in that context was my job was basically to predict the financial statements of firms in future periods. And for airlines, if you were trying to predict what this airline was going to spend in the next period or the next quarter, what you would do is you would try to think about what did they spend in the past quarter or over the past several quarters. And then you would actually, you were specifically instructed from accounting rules to pull out these unusual expenses. So if you were an airline, let's say that there was some sort of restructuring that happened or planes were grounded or there was a hurricane or a strike or any number of different things that
心理学家之前。当时我在从事股票研究，研究航空公司。在那个背景下，我注意到的一件事是，我的工作基本上是预测公司未来的财务报表。对于航空公司，如果你试图预测该航空公司在下一期或下一季度将花费多少，你会尝试思考他们在过去一个季度或过去几个季度花费了多少。然后，你实际上会根据会计准则被明确指示剔除这些异常支出。所以，如果是一家航空公司，假设发生了一些重组，或者飞机停飞，或者发生了飓风、罢工或任何其他各种各样的事情，
were unusual. Okay. So you were instructed. as the financial analyst to pull those items out and report them separately. And so when you were making your predictions, the intent was to exclude those items from what you would expect would happen in the next period. And this always seemed very interesting to me because it seemed like, well, in real life, these events keep recurring. And even in the context of the airlines at that time, something kept recurring. And like you wouldn't have a strike again the next period.
这些都是不寻常的。好的。作为财务分析师，你被指示将这些项目剔除并单独报告。因此，当你进行预测时，目的是将这些项目从你预期下一期会发生的事情中排除。这对我来说总是非常有趣，因为我觉得，在现实生活中，这些事件会不断重演。即使在当时航空公司的背景下，某些事情也在不断重演。就像你不会在下一期再次发生罢工，
maybe there would be a hurricane the next period or something damaged to the airline fleet or whatever it was. And that led me to investigate the same kind of prediction error in the context of consumers. And so what I've found in my research is that people are very bad at predicting the idea that something unusual will happen when they don't know what that's going to be. And so maybe like I'm spending extra money this quarter because it's Halloween and I have Halloween decorations. and candy and whatever else. And then suddenly it's like, you know, now it's the next month and it's Thanksgiving, but Thanksgiving doesn't happen again in December. In December, it's Christmas. And then in January, it's New Year's and in February it's, it's Valentine's Day. And so each one of these times,
但也许下一期会有飓风，或者机队受到损坏，或者其他什么情况。这促使我调查消费者背景下同样的预测错误。我在研究中发现，人们在不知道会发生什么的情况下，非常不擅长预测“会有不寻常的事情发生”这一事实。所以，也许我这个季度多花了钱，因为是万圣节，我买了万圣节装饰品、糖果等等。然后突然间，现在是下个月，是感恩节，但感恩节在十二月不会再发生一次。十二月是圣诞节，一月是新年，二月是情人节。所以每一次，
it's like, well, no, Valentine's Day is not happening again in March, right? So, and each time you're right that that particular expense is not going to recur. And so I think that there's something, thing around the psychology of it's it's very easy to think about what is the baseline set of expenses that we have. So am I going to predict my grocery bills? Yes. Like that's going to be sort of easy to predict my, you know, the cost of my mortgage or my rent. Like, yes, I'm going to do that. And the cost of like, you know, usually I go out to dinner, you know, three times a month and I'm going to plan for that too. So that stuff is sort of stable and it factors very much into our predictions. but what doesn't factor into these predictions are these outlier expenses.
就像是，“好吧，情人节在三月不会再发生一次，对吧？”所以，每一次你都是对的，那笔特定的支出不会再发生。所以我认为，关于心理学，有一点是：我们很容易想到我们的基准支出是多少。比如，我会预测我的杂货账单吗？是的，这很容易预测。我的抵押贷款或租金成本呢？是的，我会这样做。还有，比如我通常一个月出去吃三次饭，我也会为此做计划。所以这些东西是稳定的，它们很大程度上被纳入了我们的预测中。但没有被纳入这些预测的是那些异常支出。
And in some sense, as I think evidenced by this example from financial analysts, maybe they shouldn't because that particular expense isn't going to recur. But in practice, what happens is that when you think about this category of unusual expenses, there's likely to be something that will fill that spot. And so it's really good to leave a placeholder to say, here's the thing that I'm not going to expect. We're going to leave a buffer for that. Right. And do people tend to do that or is that just impossible?
在某种意义上，正如财务分析师的例子所证明的那样，也许它们不应该被纳入，因为那笔特定的支出不会再发生。但在实践中，当你想起这类异常支出时，很可能会有其他事情填补那个空缺。所以，留出一个占位符来表示“这是我没预料到的事情，我们要为此留出一个缓冲”是非常好的。没错。人们倾向于这样做吗？还是说这根本不可能？
I mean, you know, there were rules about you should have how many months of expenses in a rainy day fund just in case, one of those just in case things. Why is that such a problem for us? So I guess there are two different things. One is like you can have money that's set aside for a rainy day fund. but the question is, should you be tapping into that or should you actually plan on having that be part of your budget? Right? Like, you shouldn't, you should have that as part of your rainy day fund. That's a separate question.
我的意思是，你知道，有一些规则建议你应该有几个月的应急基金，以防万一。为什么这对我们来说是个难题？所以我想有两件不同的事情。一是你可以有一笔留作应急基金的钱，但问题是，你应该动用那笔钱，还是应该计划将其作为预算的一部分？对吧？你不应该动用它，你应该将其作为应急基金的一部分。这是一个单独的问题。
And some of us are able to set aside that money and some of us aren't. But the question is on a monthly basis, why do we need to tap into the rainy day fund? Why can't we just plan for that in our budget, right? Like, why can't we anticipate these expenses? And what we find, and so this is in research led by Chuck Howard, in terms of this expense, the sort of prediction error is that you can ask people basically repeatedly, how much did you spend last week? They'll say $100.
我们中的一些人能够存下那笔钱，而另一些人则不能。但问题是，在每月的基础上，为什么我们需要动用应急基金？为什么我们不能在预算中为此做好计划呢？为什么我们不能预见这些支出呢？我们发现——这是由 Chuck Howard 领导的研究——关于这种支出，这种预测错误在于，你可以基本上反复问人们：“你上周花了多少钱？”他们会说 100 美元。
How much do you think you're going to spend next week? $80. Okay, a week later, how much did you spend last week, $100? How much you're going to spend next week? $80. And people actually will just keep doing this over and over again. And what happens is that people essentially are predicting their modal spending and they're failing to anticipate any of these sorts of outlier expenses.
“你认为下周你会花多少钱？”80 美元。好吧，一周后，“你上周花了多少钱？”100 美元。“你下周打算花多少钱？”80 美元。人们实际上会一遍又一遍地这样做。发生的情况是，人们本质上是在预测他们的“众数支出”（最常发生的支出），而未能预见到任何这类异常支出。
Now, if you get people to stop and reflect on what do you think is going to be different next week and to pause and think through this, they are able to identify what those differences are likely to be. But at baseline, it's not what comes naturally to people. Instead, they're just going to think about what were the things that I spent money on last month, which of those are going to recur and sort of only project the ones that are going to recur. and sort of only project the ones that are going to recur going forward, and that's where you get this gap. And, you know, one of the other consequences of focusing on this is that people tend to actually spend more on these one-off expenses than they might otherwise because they think of them
现在，如果你让人们停下来反思一下“你认为下周会有什么不同”，并暂停下来仔细思考，他们确实能够识别出这些差异可能是什么。但在基准情况下，这不是人们自然而然会做的事情。相反，他们只会考虑上个月我在哪些方面花了钱，其中哪些会再次发生，并只预测那些会再次发生的支出，这就是差距产生的地方。而且，你知道，关注这一点的另一个后果是，人们往往在这些一次性支出上花得比原本可能花的更多，因为他们认为这些支出
as exceptional. And so if I think, you know, this particular kind of expense, it's like I'm buying a birthday present, for example, this only happens once a year. Well, then I can afford to spend more on it. And so it also licenses you again because I'm not thinking about it as a recurring expense. And so the cost is only one higher price rather than 15 higher prices if you think about the fact that similar kinds of expenses occur 15 times throughout the year. So how do stores and retailers take advantage of the psychological biases we experience when they're trying to sell us products? Yeah, so I think that that's a very broad question. And I think there are many different things that stores do in terms of, one is bringing this idea back to the buy now, pay later plans, which is really how do you think about the costs and the benefits and the timing. of various costs and benefits. And so to the extent that you can focus people on the benefits that they'll get today and the costs that will come later. So I'm advertising that you can get this
是例外的。所以如果我想，“这种特定的支出，比如我买一份生日礼物，这每年只发生一次。”好吧，那么我就可以负担得起多花点钱。所以这也给了你一种许可，因为我没有把它当作经常性支出。因此，成本只是一个较高的价格，而不是如果你考虑到类似的支出在一年中会发生 15 次，那就是 15 个较高的价格。那么，商店和零售商在试图向我们推销产品时，是如何利用我们所经历的心理偏差的呢？是的，我认为这是一个非常广泛的问题。我认为商店在很多方面都会这样做，其中一点是回到“先买后付”计划的理念，这实际上是你如何思考各种成本和收益的成本、收益和时间安排。因此，在某种程度上，你可以让人们关注他们今天将获得的收益和稍后才会出现的成本。所以我做广告说你可以得到这个
today and have a delayed payment. Another thing is just potentially increasing the extent to which products seem like they're necessary. And so here, companies can be very good at helping combine or bundle products together and advertise what might actually be something that's a superfluous product, but that feels like, well, if I'm buying this, I'll actually probably save money over time by buying this additional complement. So those are, I think, just two examples. In addition to just being so good at predicting things that you might want and suddenly feel like you actually need to have them. So I think firms have gotten very good at predicting their customers' needs to needs and wants and desires and increasingly sort of throwing in more tempting options together.
今天购买，延迟付款。另一件事是潜在地增加产品看起来是“必需品”的程度。在这里，公司非常擅长帮助组合或捆绑产品，并宣传那些可能实际上是多余的产品，但感觉上是，“如果我买了它，通过购买这个额外的补充产品，我实际上可能会随着时间的推移省钱。”所以我认为这只是两个例子。此外，他们还非常擅长预测你可能想要的东西，让你突然觉得你实际上需要拥有它们。所以我认为企业已经非常擅长预测客户的需求、愿望和欲望，并越来越多地将更多诱人的选项组合在一起。
And of course, AI keeps pushing things at us whether we want them or not. So one day you go and you look at a pair of shoes and now for the next three weeks, all you see in your feet is shoes, shoes, shoes. And they're like, I guess I did want those. Or you left this in your card. You know, all of those kinds of little tips and tricks. You looked at this on eBay. It's still for sale.
当然，人工智能无论我们是否想要，都在不断地向我们推送东西。所以有一天你去看了双鞋，接下来的三周里，你看到的都是鞋子、鞋子、鞋子。他们就像是，“我想我确实想要那些。”或者你把这个留在了购物车里。你知道，所有这些小技巧。你在 eBay 上看了这个。它还在卖。
You know, come back. The price just came down. down $100. Exactly. Right. And I think that the price just came down is another interesting one, right? Like, how do firms think about advertising discounts? How do firms take advantage of sort of a limited time opportunity, right? So I think from a scarcity perspective, you don't want to miss out on an opportunity, and that opportunity can be a discount as well. And that's something that, right, people get a lot of value from feeling like they've gotten a deal. And that's another place where we see, where we see stores taking, I mean, being very aware of what they're doing. The more you spend,
你知道，回来吧。价格刚刚降了 100 美元。没错。而且我认为“价格刚刚降了”是另一个有趣的例子，对吧？企业如何考虑广告折扣？企业如何利用某种限时机会，对吧？所以我认为从稀缺性的角度来看，你不想错过机会，而那个机会也可以是折扣。这是人们从感觉自己得到了优惠中获得很多价值的东西。这是我们看到商店利用这一点的另一个地方，我的意思是，他们非常清楚自己在做什么。你花得越多，
the more you save. Right. Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill for burner gas grill on special buy for only $199. And entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $499. This Memorial Day
你省得越多。没错。你的夏天从家得宝 (The Home Depot) 的阵亡将士纪念日优惠开始。是时候用 Next Grill 四炉燃气烤架来开启夏季烧烤了，特价仅需 199 美元。整个季节都可以用 Hampton Bay West Grove 七件套户外餐桌椅来招待客人，仅需 499 美元。这个阵亡将士纪念日，
get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot. While supplies last, price invalid May 14th or May 27th, U.S. only exclusions apply. See Home Depot.com slash price match for details. You said this place was steps from the water. We just haven't found the steps yet.
在家得宝获得低价保证。售完即止，价格有效期为 5 月 14 日至 5 月 27 日，仅限美国，适用排除条款。详情请参阅 HomeDepot.com/pricematch。你说这个地方离水边只有几步之遥。我们只是还没找到那几步路。
How much did we save? Enough. Enough to get lost! Or you could book a stay with Hilton. Welcome to your oceanfront room. Just steps from the water. The Hilton sale is on now. Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app and save up to 20% to get the stay you expected.
我们省了多少钱？够了。足够让我们迷路了！或者你可以预订希尔顿酒店的住宿。欢迎来到您的海滨客房。距离水边仅几步之遥。希尔顿促销活动现已开始。在 Hilton.com 或希尔顿应用程序上预订，最高可享 8 折优惠，获得您期待的住宿体验。
When you want savings, not surprises. It matters where you stay. Hilton for the stay. We're going to take a short break. When we return, I'll talk with Dr. Sussman about keeping up with the Joneses and how people think differently about wealth and debt when they're comparing their own spending with their neighbors' spending. Now, you've also studied how people think differently about wealth and debt when they're comparing
当你想要节省开支，而不是意外时。你住在哪里很重要。希尔顿，为了这次住宿。我们要休息一下。回来后，我将与 Sussman 博士讨论“攀比心理”，以及人们在将自己的消费与邻居的消费进行比较时，如何以不同的方式看待财富和债务。现在，您还研究了人们在比较
their own spending to their neighbors' spending. How does social comparisons shape our spending and saving behaviors? Yeah. So one of the things I think that was the insight of this paper that you're mentioning with Raphael Batista and Jennifer Trueblood, one of the insights there is basically, that when we think about social comparison, there's been a lot of work for many, many, many, many years on conspicuous consumption, thinking about we observe what other people are purchasing, and we draw inferences from that. And similarly, we want to consume fancy cars, fancy clothing,
自己的消费与邻居的消费时，如何以不同的方式看待财富和债务。社会比较如何塑造我们的消费和储蓄行为？是的。我认为这篇与 Raphael Batista 和 Jennifer Trueblood 合著的论文的洞察力之一，基本上是当我们思考社会比较时，多年来已经有很多关于“炫耀性消费”的研究，思考我们观察别人购买什么，并从中得出推论。同样，我们想要消费昂贵的汽车、昂贵的服装，
right, that we know other people are going to look at and they're going to think more highly of us, for example, for consuming those things. One of the things that is less visible and generally actually not talked about at all is not the consumption side of things, but the saving and debt side, right? And so we really don't know how much debt somebody has. We don't know how much money somebody has in their savings account. And I think that to some degree, this puts us as a society at a huge disadvantage because you end up at this keeping up with the Joneses for, in some sense, the things that are maybe the least important aspects of consumption, whereas the things that actually provide us with financial stability and feelings of financial comfort, which are really
对吧，我们知道别人会看，并且会因为我们消费这些东西而对我们评价更高。其中不太明显且通常根本不被谈论的一点不是消费方面，而是储蓄和债务方面，对吧？所以我们真的不知道某人有多少债务。我们不知道某人的储蓄账户里有多少钱。我认为在某种程度上，这使我们作为一个社会处于巨大的劣势，因为你最终会陷入这种“攀比心理”，在某种意义上，是为了那些可能最不重要的消费方面，而那些实际上为我们提供财务稳定感和财务舒适感的方面，是非常
important, are not going to be sending any sort of signal of status. And so what ends up happening is that we evaluate people based on their spending. And I think that the fact that if we look at what somebody else has spent, we don't have visibility into the debt that they took on, let's say. In our own spending, we're very aware of the debt. And so when we think about sort of evaluating how wealthy does this make me feel, I'm going to be very sensitive to how much debt I took on in order to make this particular purchase and not evaluating somebody else. And so this has the potential to actually really aggravate and exacerbate this conspicuous consumption cycle. Between inflation and job instability, a lot of people are feeling financially stressed right now.
重要的，却不会发出任何地位信号。所以最终发生的是，我们根据人们的消费来评价他们。我认为，如果我们看别人花了多少钱，我们无法看到他们承担的债务，比如说。在我们自己的消费中，我们非常清楚债务。所以当我们思考“这让我感觉多富有”时，我会对为了进行这次特定购买而承担了多少债务非常敏感，而不是去评价别人。因此，这有可能真正加剧和恶化这种炫耀性消费循环。在通货膨胀和就业不稳定的双重压力下，很多人现在感到财务压力很大。
How do stress and economic uncertainty change the way that people make spending decisions? Yeah. So this is, I think, a really important question right now. And I think that in many cases, it makes people more myopic. And so I'm going to be more focused on what is my budget this month. And I'm going to be really, focused on trying to stay within my means for, let's say, I would set specific budget categories. And on a day-to-day basis, make sure that I'm spending less. But I'm more likely to lose sight of the bigger picture financial goals. And so one of the things that we find is that people with lower incomes and more financial instability actually find budgeting also less pleasant and are less likely to do it.
压力和经济不确定性如何改变人们做出消费决策的方式？是的。我认为这是一个非常重要的问题。我认为在许多情况下，它使人们变得更加“近视”。所以我会更关注我这个月的预算是多少。我会非常专注于尝试量入为出，比如说，我会设定具体的预算类别。在日常生活中，确保我花得更少。但我更容易忽视更大的财务目标。所以我们发现的一件事是，收入较低和财务状况更不稳定的人实际上发现预算编制也不那么令人愉快，而且不太可能这样做。
But conditional on engaging in budgeting, people are checking their budgets more, right? So it becomes more of an exercise of making ends meet rather than thinking about striving for something better or thinking about longer-term financial goals, which is just one of the, I think just something that falls out naturally from the constraints and limitations. Another related piece of work looks at the effect of actually losing one's job on financial risk-taking. And in this work with Sam Hirschman and Jennifer Trueblood, we find that actually after losing one's job, people spend less overall, but actually the amount that they spend on something like, gambling or other kinds of risky financial behaviors decreases relatively less than other spending. And so what this suggests is that people really are hoping to make up for the amount that they've
但如果参与预算编制，人们会更多地检查他们的预算，对吧？所以它更多地变成了一种“维持生计”的练习，而不是思考争取更好的东西或思考更长期的财务目标，这只是从约束和限制中自然产生的结果。另一项相关工作着眼于失业对财务风险承担的影响。在这项与 Sam Hirschman 和 Jennifer Trueblood 的研究中，我们发现实际上在失业后，人们的总支出减少了，但实际上他们在赌博或其他类型的风险财务行为上的支出，相对于其他支出减少得较少。所以这表明人们确实希望弥补他们
lost in these kinds of financial shock kinds of experiences. So overall spending less, but still trying to remain in some sense like optimistic around this risk-taking behavior. Do you have advice for people who would like to do a better job of sticking to their budget? Are there, is anything in your research that suggests strategies that we can use in our everyday lives? For sure. So I think there are a couple of things. So one is trying to set a realistic budget in the first place. I think that's going to be key.
在这些财务冲击经历中损失的金额。所以总支出减少了，但仍然试图在某种程度上对这种风险承担行为保持乐观。对于那些希望更好地坚持预算的人，您有什么建议吗？您的研究中是否有任何建议可以让我们在日常生活中使用？当然。我认为有几件事。一是首先尝试设定一个现实的预算。我认为这是关键。
And so that includes things like either leaving a buffer for unusual kinds of expenses or one-off expenses. And you could think about rather than. going back and thinking on a category by category basis, how much have I spent in each month, let's say, look at your aggregate spending and try to make sure that your budget matches the aggregate level of spending rather than summing up from the bottom by category, if that makes sense, either by, you know, increasing the amount in each category or adding a separate bucket. Another thing is around this impulsivity and sort of buying based on the pair of shoes that was shown to you at each different website that you went to, right? And so
这包括诸如为异常支出或一次性支出留出缓冲等事项。你可以考虑，而不是回到按类别思考每个月花了多少钱，看看你的总支出，并尝试确保你的预算与总支出水平相匹配，而不是从底部按类别汇总，如果这有意义的话，可以通过增加每个类别的金额或添加一个单独的桶来实现。另一件事是关于这种冲动，以及基于你在每个不同网站上看到的鞋子进行购买，对吧？所以
one of the things that's happened, I think, a lot is around just automating the purchasing process and reducing frictions for spending. And so if you, for me, like say, like, right, if I go online to any store, all of a sudden, the internet has my credit card information, like, my computer has my information stored in five different ways. And it used to be like you had to, well, it used to be, you had to take out cash from your wallet and you had to be in a store to make a payment. You thought a lot about what that payment was going to be right before you made it. It was psychologically costly in addition to the dollar cost to separate with that money. And now I don't even need to take out my credit card to make a payment.
我认为发生了很多事情，就是关于自动化购买过程和减少消费摩擦。所以如果你，对我来说，比如，对吧，如果我上网到任何商店，突然间，互联网就有了我的信用卡信息，比如，我的电脑以五种不同的方式存储了我的信息。过去，你必须，好吧，过去，你必须从钱包里拿出钱，你必须在商店里付款。在付款之前，你对那笔付款会是什么样子思考了很多。除了金钱成本之外，分离那笔钱在心理上也是有代价的。现在我甚至不需要拿出信用卡来付款。
I just have to keep sort of clicking through and everything is automatically filled in for me. And so to the extent that we can reintroduce frictions into our spending, this is something that's helpful. And so making rules for yourself could be, I'm only going to buy in person would be one kind of rule. That comes with other challenges, which is like now you're at the store and now you're tempted by all the different things in the store. So sort of going with a more concrete plan in that case. But I think just removing your credit card online, you know, taking it down from Google Pay. and Apple pay. These kinds of things will just lead us to pause and reflect and we can still buy all of the things that we want to buy, but really making sure that we've thought through these
我只需要不断点击，一切都会自动为我填写。因此，在我们可以重新引入消费摩擦的范围内，这是有帮助的。所以为自己制定规则可以是“我只会在实体店购买”，这将是一种规则。这带来了其他挑战，比如现在你在商店里，现在你被商店里各种各样的东西诱惑了。所以在那种情况下，带着更具体的计划去。但我认为，只要在网上删除你的信用卡，你知道，从 Google Pay 和 Apple Pay 中删除它。这些事情只会引导我们暂停和反思，我们仍然可以购买我们想要购买的所有东西，但真正确保我们已经仔细思考了这些
decisions, I think is going to be one valuable component. And then the other is to try to be thoughtful about when we're spending. So setting aside specific times to be making purchases as opposed to either being online and sort of shopping out of, you know, different sorts of emotions or boredom or going to the supermarket even and you can go to the supermarket when you're starving or you can go to the supermarket when you've come with a plan. And if you go when you're starving, like probably you leave with a lot of Kit Katz and not necessarily the food that you needed.
决策，我认为这将是一个有价值的组成部分。另一个是尝试在消费时保持深思熟虑。所以设定特定的时间进行购买，而不是上网，或者出于各种情绪或无聊而购物，甚至去超市，你可以在饥肠辘辘时去超市，也可以在有计划时去超市。如果你在饥肠辘辘时去，你可能会带着很多奇巧巧克力离开，而不是你真正需要的食物。
And so going, right, and so being thoughtful, we sometimes think about this as, as spending in a cold state, like when your emotions are low and you're not in sort of the heat of the moment. So we can think about that from a hunger perspective would be the analog for a grocery store, but you can think about this from other perspectives as well, depending on what the kind of purchase is. But trying to sort of take the emotion out of the spending is another way to think about restraining our spending and staying within our budgets. There seem to be a lot of apps out there these days that promise that they're going to help you get your financial life in order. And, you know, I get all these ads for, I'm not going to name it because they're not a sponsor.
所以，去吧，对吧，保持深思熟虑，我们有时认为这是在“冷静状态”下消费，就像当你的情绪低落，不在那种“热血沸腾”的时刻一样。所以我们可以从饥饿的角度来思考这个问题，作为杂货店的类比，但你也可以根据购买的种类从其他角度来思考。但尝试将情绪从消费中剥离出来，是限制我们的消费并保持在预算范围内的另一种思考方式。现在市面上似乎有很多应用程序承诺能帮助你理清财务生活。而且，你知道，我收到了所有这些广告，我不会点名，因为他们不是赞助商。
But there's a particular app that tells you, you know, you've got four subscriptions to Netflix and you haven't watched Hulu in six months. And I'll cancel these things for you. Do those apps really work for people? Or are we that sad that we don't know how much we're subscribing to at this point? We need something else, something external to tell us. I think that the topic of subscriptions is actually a big problem. People do not unsubscribe. So I actually think a lot of people have subscriptions that they are not paying attention to,
但有一个特定的应用程序告诉你，你知道，你有四个 Netflix 订阅，而且你已经六个月没看 Hulu 了。我会为你取消这些东西。这些应用程序真的对人们有效吗？还是我们太悲哀了，以至于不知道自己订阅了多少东西？我们需要别的东西，一些外部的东西来告诉我们。我认为订阅这个话题实际上是一个大问题。人们不取消订阅。所以我实际上认为很多人有他们没有注意到的订阅，
that they're not aware of, that are automatically renewing. it's incredibly difficult. I mean, I don't know incredibly difficult, but oftentimes, right, signing up for something is very easy and you frequently will click a button that says auto renew or you won't be allowed to sign up unless you agree to auto renewal. So I actually think the topic of apps is sort of, it depends on what the app is and how helpful it could be. Like surely there are apps out there that can be helpful for managing your finances.
他们不知道的，正在自动续订的。这非常困难。我的意思是，我不确定是否非常困难，但通常情况下，对吧，注册某样东西非常容易，你经常会点击一个写着“自动续订”的按钮，或者如果你不同意自动续订，你就不被允许注册。所以我实际上认为应用程序这个话题，这取决于应用程序是什么以及它有多大帮助。当然，市面上肯定有一些应用程序可以帮助管理你的财务。
I mean, one of the things that apps do is they also select on people who care and are focused on it, right? They bring your attention to these issues, which I think, again, can be very valuable. I think for many people, it's easy to lose track of it. And companies are not always reminding you before that payment comes due, right? Why would they? Why would they? Exactly. You've also looked at how people think about the tradeoff between savings and debt,
我的意思是，应用程序所做的一件事是，它们也筛选出那些关心并专注于此的人，对吧？它们让你关注这些问题，我认为这再次是非常有价值的。我认为对许多人来说，很容易忘记这一点。而且公司并不总是在付款到期前提醒你，对吧？他们为什么要提醒？他们为什么要提醒？没错。您还研究了人们如何思考储蓄和债务之间的权衡，
especially something that's called co-holding, I think I mentioned in the intro, people have credit card debt, but they also have money in savings and they could pay off that debt. Does this ever make financial sense? And if not, why is it so common? Yeah, for sure. So this is something that's quite common behavior. And there are cases where it could make financial sense. So for example, if you're worried that you won't have access to liquidity from your credit card in the future, then maybe you need that sort of savings buffer because that's the only way that you'll have cash to pay bills. That's the sort of thing that could make financial sense. I think for many people who are engaging in co-holding, that's not the case, right? They would have, if you paid down
特别是所谓的“共同持有”，我想我在介绍中提到过，人们有信用卡债务，但他们也有储蓄，他们本可以还清债务。这在财务上真的有意义吗？如果不是，为什么它如此普遍？是的，当然。这是相当普遍的行为。在某些情况下，它在财务上是有意义的。例如，如果你担心未来无法从信用卡获得流动性，那么也许你需要那种储蓄缓冲，因为那是你拥有现金支付账单的唯一方式。这是在财务上可能有意义的事情。我认为对于许多参与“共同持有”的人来说，情况并非如此，对吧？他们本可以，如果你还清了
your credit card bill this month, you could continue to borrow on credit the next month, for example. And I think there's also a question with co-holding of sort of how much money do you have in cash and how much money should you have in cash from a comfort or savings perspective. So I think that there's definitely complexity there, but I think that a lot of what happens with co-holding, and there have been many different explanations proposed largely within the economics literature, I think that there's also something psychological going on where we feel responsible for having money and savings, and we're able to, because of mental accounting, we mentally segregate savings in debt. So we don't think of it as having one pool of money, and that money is basically
你这个月的信用卡账单，你下个月可以继续用信用卡借贷，例如。而且我认为“共同持有”也存在一个问题，即从舒适度或储蓄的角度来看，你应该有多少现金，你应该有多少现金。所以我认为那里肯定存在复杂性，但我认为“共同持有”中发生的很多事情，经济学文献中提出了许多不同的解释，我认为也存在一些心理因素，我们觉得有责任在储蓄中存钱，并且由于“心理账户”，我们能够在心理上将储蓄和债务分开。所以我们不认为这是一个单一的资金池，而那笔钱基本上是
right. Our savings minus our debt. Instead, we think of it as two distinct pools. And so our savings is on the right. Our debt is on the left. And to the extent that you think about these two things as distinct pools, well, what do people who are financially secure have? They have money and savings. And so if I want to feel responsible, I'm going to have money and savings too. And so this is something that I've worked on with work O'Brien looking at what happens. when the amount of the money that you have in savings is designated for different purposes. So if you think about this money that I've set aside in savings for something really responsible, so for my kids' education, for example, I'm not going to touch that.
没错。我们的储蓄减去我们的债务。相反，我们认为它是两个不同的池子。所以我们的储蓄在右边。我们的债务在左边。在某种程度上，你认为这两件事是不同的池子，好吧，财务安全的人有什么？他们有储蓄。所以如果我想感到负责任，我也会在储蓄中存钱。这是我与 Work O'Brien 合作研究的内容，看看当你在储蓄中拥有的钱被指定用于不同目的时会发生什么。所以如果你认为这笔我存入储蓄用于非常负责任的事情的钱，比如为了我孩子的教育，我不会动用它。
And if some expense comes along, I'm going to instead borrow on my credit card because, of course, I'm not touching, you know, money that I've set aside for my kid or whatever it is. If I have money set aside for my vacation, I'll be more likely to draw that down. And so I do think people are able to segregate and say, like, yeah, it's bad that I have money in debt, but it's really important that I have money in savings. And what are these two things even have to do with each other? And so more recently in work led by Raphael Batista again, we've done some research where we've worked with a large bank in Australia and we've partnered with them to actually run experiments where we're able to send people. banking app notifications telling them that they have money in both savings and debt. And basically that this is a costly for them to do that their credit card debt is, you know, they're being charged high, you know, 15% interest, let's say, versus 1% interest that they're that they're getting on their on their savings accounts.
如果出现了一些支出，我会转而使用信用卡借贷，因为当然，我不会动用我为孩子存下的钱或任何其他东西。如果我为度假存了钱，我更有可能动用那笔钱。所以我确实认为人们能够区分并说：“是的，我有债务很糟糕，但我在储蓄中有钱真的很重要。”这两件事甚至有什么关系？所以最近在 Raphael Batista 再次领导的工作中，我们进行了一些研究，我们与澳大利亚的一家大银行合作，我们与他们合作进行了实验，我们能够向人们发送银行应用程序通知，告诉他们他们在储蓄和债务中都有钱。基本上，这样做对他们来说代价高昂，他们的信用卡债务，你知道，他们被收取高额的，比如说 15% 的利息，而他们在储蓄账户上获得的利息只有 1%。
And so sending these sorts of in-app notifications. And what we find is that it actually has minimal effect on behavior. So it doesn't seem like most people are doing this sort of by accident, but instead it's quite deliberate. And so in more recent work, we're also looking into the idea that one of the things that we've noticed in terms of digging into transaction data around these customers is that the customers that tend to be co-holding tend also to be using their debit cards more. for transactions. And so this suggests that an additional factor beyond what I've already been talking about is that for people who want to be spending on their debit card in particular for everyday transactions, you need to have some kind of savings buffer around in order to spend on your debit card. And so it's actually, it's not the comfort with credit that allows these people to be coholding,
所以发送这类应用内通知。我们发现它对行为的影响微乎其微。所以大多数人似乎并不是偶然这样做的，而是相当刻意的。所以在最近的工作中，我们也在研究这样一个想法：我们在挖掘这些客户的交易数据时注意到的一件事是，倾向于“共同持有”的客户也倾向于更多地使用他们的借记卡进行交易。所以这表明，除了我一直在谈论的内容之外，还有一个额外的因素，即对于那些特别想在日常交易中使用借记卡的人来说，你需要有一些储蓄缓冲才能使用借记卡。所以实际上，并不是对信贷的舒适度让这些人能够共同持有，
but instead it's almost a discomfort with credit of, right, I want to, I want to be more focused on the fact that I have this money and savings that's available. That can be the driver. Again, treating these two pools is like really distinct. Right, right. So just to wrap up, what are the big questions that you are still trying to answer? What are you working on right now? So great question.
但相反，这几乎是一种对信贷的不适感，对吧？我想，我想更专注于这样一个事实：我有这笔钱和储蓄可用。这可以成为驱动力。再次强调，将这两个资金池视为真正不同的东西。对，对。那么总结一下，你还在试图回答哪些大问题？你现在正在研究什么？问得好。
There are a handful of different topics. One that I'll mention just because it relates to some of the earlier points that have come up. but is in terms of thinking about buy now pay later plans and wealth signaling these were sort of two different topics that came up earlier and one of the the projects that I've been working on has been looking at what happens when you are using a buy now pay later plan or any other form of payment method what are the kind of wealth signals that people derive from this and so typically we think about wealth signaling as being really around these highly conspicuous behaviors, or specifically purchases is sort of the most traditional version of this, right?
有几个不同的主题。我提一个，仅仅因为它与之前提到的一些观点有关。但在考虑“先买后付”计划和财富信号方面，这是之前出现的两个不同主题，我一直在研究的项目之一是观察当你使用“先买后付”计划或任何其他支付方式时会发生什么，人们从中获取什么样的财富信号？通常我们认为财富信号确实围绕着这些高度显眼的消费行为，或者具体来说，购买是这种行为最传统的版本，对吧？
I buy a fancy car, for example. And these are also sort of long-lasting transactions, right? Or sort of you have the car and you're displaying it all day long to your friends. But what we're proposing in this research is that in addition to the purchases themselves, that actually the way that you make the purchase can send a way. wealth signal, both externally, let's say, to the retail, like to the store employee, but also internally can send a signal of status to yourself as well over how you feel about making the purchase. And so using the Buy Now Pay Later plan versus a credit card versus a platinum
例如，我买了一辆豪车。这些也属于某种持久的交易，对吧？或者说你拥有这辆车，并且整天向你的朋友展示它。但我们在研究中提出的是，除了购买行为本身之外，实际上你进行购买的方式也可以发送一种财富信号，既是对外的，比如对零售店员，也是对内的，可以向你自己发送一种地位信号，关于你对进行这次购买的感觉。因此，使用“先买后付”计划与信用卡或白金卡相比
amex card, actually the method of payment can make us feel differently about the expense, which can then have potentially downstream consequences for our likelihood of sort of continuing to use these methods and to return to the same stores going forward. Well, Dr. Sussman, I want to thank you for joining me today. This has been illuminating. Thank you so much for having me. Really fun conversation. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingofpsychology.
美国运通卡，实际上支付方式会让我们对这笔开支有不同的感觉，这可能会对我们未来继续使用这些方式并回到同一家商店的可能性产生潜在的后续影响。好的，萨斯曼博士，我想感谢你今天加入我的节目。这非常有启发性。非常感谢你的邀请。非常有趣的谈话。你可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology 上找到《心理学谈话》之前的剧集。
Or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please follow us and leave a rating. If you have comments or ideas for future episodes, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. Enjoy more ways to save at Ralph's, like low prices in every aisle. And when you download the Ralph's app, you can clip and save more with digital coupons every week.
或者在 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或任何你获取播客的地方。如果你喜欢你所听到的内容，请关注我们并留下评分。如果你对未来的剧集有评论或想法，你可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由 Lee Wynerman 制作。感谢收听美国心理学会的节目。我是 Kim Mills。在 Ralph's 享受更多省钱方式，比如每个过道的低价。当你下载 Ralph's 应用程序时，你可以每周通过数字优惠券剪辑并节省更多。
Plus, you can earn fuel points to save up to $1 per gallon at the pump. At Ralph's, you can enjoy more ways to save and more rewards every time you shop. So it's always easy to save big every day with savings and rewards. Ralph's SoCal for over 150 years. Savings may vary by state. Fuel restrictions apply. See site for details. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
此外，你可以赚取燃油积分，在加油站每加仑最多可节省 1 美元。在 Ralph's，你每次购物都可以享受更多省钱方式和更多奖励。因此，通过储蓄和奖励，每天都能轻松省大钱。Ralph's SoCal 超过 150 年。储蓄可能因州而异。燃油限制适用。详情请参阅网站。此剧集尚无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。